[Music]
right we're here at the hubmer family
farm in blue arth County just south of
Mano the hubmer is participate in the
USDA conservation stewardship program
which promotes sustainable farming
practices they produce non-GMO crops
which they feed to their birkshire Hogs
and their Freer range chickens I'm Joel
Jones with spnn and in this episode of
Market we're going to find out what
sustainable farming practices mean to
the land the crops and the
livestock hey
Roger hello first we're going to look at
our new building that we just put up
this spring right on many years in the
making this is a truck she takes to the
farmers
market nice big
freezer got everything all indexed where
the location of all the meat and
everything is right now this is running
5 below zero in there so it's cold I
guess so come on
in these are the chickens here that we
raise different
sausages all brand new components so
we're pretty happy should last for a
long
time looks pretty state-of-the-art I
mean you're taking your fresh product
and it's coming straight from the
butcher into here and then we're getting
it at the St Paul Farmers Market how
about you show us some of the crops
outside
sure well we were losing quite a lot of
money just selling pigs on the open
market so we switched to the direct
marketing this is so much more rewarding
to sell to customers that can really
appreciate the product that you
have so Roger what is this Ridge tilling
that you keep talking about well Ridge
tilling is a type of tillage we use we
don't use the mboard plow chisel plow
field culator all we do is is we come in
here I planted these soybeans I actually
planted these soybeans right into
standing residue if you can see here
right here is where the old cornrow was
a year ago and I planted it right into
there well you look at all this residue
now what's wrong with that residue why
do we have to get rid of that residue
and plow it under no need to run a big
300 horsepower tractor to to bury a
residue I got it right there on top hols
down the weeds keeps the moisture in
which is real important in during this
drought season here and eliminates
erosion too because as the raindrops hit
it it doesn't uh wash the soil away
this
ground this ground is so soft and mellow
and uh we got it's full of earthworms in
here they do all the ariation for me
makes it very
porous and absorbent for water I
experimented with it the first year I
did it the beans that I had on ridges
yielded four bushel better than the
conventionally uh raised beans does it
take more expensive equipment less less
less equipment here's here's my Ridge
steel cator right here this is an Orman
cator and uh here's our cator shovels
that is kind of sunk in the ground and
as you go through it it it cuts the
weeds off plus as the dirts coming these
ridges ridgers here throw the dirt
across and that's that healing effect
that I was telling you about and this
this cter here cuts through that that
trash
residue as is going through there so it
doesn't plug up these things here
nobody's Cates anymore with all the
Roundup chemicals that are available so
I found this for basically the cost of
scrap iron I paid $1,500 for this
machine new I bet you it would be 25 to
30,000 so do you have to fertilize as
much because of the way you're doing the
ridge till no that's another nice thing
about it too because we do what you call
strip till or banding fertilizer we're
going to come in there this fall and
we're going to put our strip of
fertilizer right where the corn is going
to be planted next year and so that root
is going to be right in the fertilizer
instead of broadcasting it over the top
and we can get by with about 50% of the
fertilizer that way I also laid on a
cover crop you can see some of this this
was part of my cover crop this is vetch
I planted rye and vet I spread a bunch
of rye and vetch seed out here and then
this spring I killed it it and planted
these beans right into it and I don't
think these beans look too bad
considering we're going through one of
the worst droughts we've ever been in
good
deal now this here this is our uh manure
storage right here this is some of the
manure that we scrape out of those
gutters in there and it goes down the
gutter and it comes out that tube there
and now when we get our soybean crop off
of here this will all go back in there
so if the way I figure it out if I feed
150 bushels the corn to the Hogs that
much manure goes back on the ground so
whatever we take off the ground we put
back on the ground farmers are the
original recyclers Right comes out of
the field goes into the bin goes through
the Hogs goes into the pit goes back in
the field that's a that's a recycling
that's what we
do so to get to where you are today it
seems like you've had to do a lot of
adapting and evolving yeah it's
something new every day just dreaming
things up uh um up in the yard I got a
picture of the farm the way it used to
look when it was first built in 1920 no
trees no
nothing and uh this was originally what
it is and we've added to it in the last
92 years looks like you've maintained
the foundation of the family farm but
you've added so much more to it and
involved and we really appreciate you
letting us come out here and giving us
an inside view of your land stewardship
thank you so much Roger oh you're
welcome
[Music]
what